Ukraine's President says Russia has
launched a new offensive in the Eastern
region of the netsk and luhansk Vladimir
zielinski announced last night that the
battle for the donbass had begun and
Ukraine's military says Russian forces
are attacking positions along the entire
300 mile front line moscow's also
repeated its demand for Ukrainian and
foreign fighters to surrender in
mariopol russian-backed separatists
claimed special forces are now storming
the city still works despite pictures
emerging which purportedly show women
and children taking shelter inside the
plant
Russia's defense Ministry says its
missile and artillery forces struck
1260 Targets in Ukraine overnight
there'll be no evacuation corridors open
in Ukraine for the third consecutive day
the country's Deputy Prime Minister says
efforts to create safe passage for
civilians to leave have repeatedly
failed
the regional governor of luhansk says
the eastern city of Crema Nina is now
under Russian control Ukrainian troops
have had to withdraw and take up new
positions and the commander of the azov
Regiment of the Ukrainian National Guard
says Russia has begun dropping bunker
Buster bombs on a steel plant in
maripole where Ukrainian forces are
refusing to surrender I'm joined now to
discuss all of this and much more by air
marshal Phil Osborne former Chief of the
defense intelligence staff and a
director at Universal defense and
Security Solutions uh great to see you
again Phil and let's touch first of all
on the big picture and it feels like
this is a critical moment in this war
now yeah I think so day 55 this is
something the Russians have been working
up to for some weeks trying to regroup
and rebuild frankly some pretty
shattered military units coming round
from Kiev and the rest of Russia to
really come at the East system and
probably to focus on some revised War
aims which is to take the whole of the
donbass let's dive into that that
particular region and what do you think
are the key areas of focus for the
Russians first of all in the coming days
uh in this this area so the Russians
will I think we're fairly clear to say
this offensive has started and they're
into a proprietary phase and actually
starting to advance so they're declaring
some 1260 targets hit uh overnight and
the ukrainians actually have accepted
the criminal with a loss of some 200
civilians has been taken under Russian
control I think we can expect the
Russians to focus on advancing or trying
to advance in the East with supporting
efforts to the North and the South
hopefully from their perspective seeking
to encircle well-dug in Ukrainian forces
well let's touch on those Ukrainian
forces then what is their uh key
strategy to to repel this Russian
advance so so they've been there for
eight years they'll have defended the
the front line as they see it but also
urban areas
um they'll be tired there is the risk of
being overwhelmed the ground more suits
maneuver Warfare from a Russian
perspective so they can bring that
advantage of numbers to Bear but I think
it's fair to say they've got some things
going for them they're hugely motivated
as we've seen and also the Russians to
change the way they've been fighting is
a fairly steep ask of them they've been
pretty average thus far and therefore
it's quite a shift from a Russian point
of view to be quite different in the way
they approach Warfare at this stage are
there any whilst we stick on this image
any areas that they're pushing back
actively on or just repelling these
these Russians so the ukrainians are
will be seeking to put pressure on
Russia in different places of the
theater so for example I think we can
expect to see some counter-attacks in
the North to the north isium there's a a
well established Supply Route coming
north from Russia uh down in towards the
the donbass region I think we can also
see some counter-attacks in the South
around kers and again trying to fix
Russian forces in the South and stopping
them reinforce that Eastern offensive
really fascinating we'll see how all of
that plays out over the coming weeks
Phil but let's uh now just dive in to
maripole which of course we touched on
already but go in more detail and
somewhat amazingly Ukrainian forces
continue to resist the Russian advances
what what's going on in maripole um I
think you're right I think this this is
probably a tone from a whole of
Ukrainian point of view to be fair this
is a really hard target from a Russian
point of view and I think the ukrainians
have surprised us all by hanging on as
long as they have
in amongst the horror of Margaret Paul
this is serving a purpose of fixing
Russian forces in the South so again
part of that trying to distract Russia
from its offensive in the east
Phil great stuff thanks so much for
joining me as always